mes chers collègues il est 8h35 je vous
propose que nous débutions
cette nouvelle séance de notre
délégation à la prospective où nous
avons le plaisir aujourd'hui de recevoir
le général Michel Friedling au titre
d'une double casquette si j'ose dire
d'anciens commandant de l'espace et de
confondateur de la société lookup space
spécialisé dans les données de
surveillance de l'espace
quelques éléments de contexte comme vous
le savez nos collègues que je remercie
de leur présence Christine lavard des
evanina paoligajin travail depuis près
d'un an sur un rapport consacré à
l'exploitation des ressources spatiales
qu'elle nous présenterons la semaine
prochaine je veux vraiment les remercier
parce que je sais
qu'elles ont beaucoup positionné et
travaillés sur le sur le sujet peut-être
avez-vous parfois l'impression que ce
sujet
épouse celui de la science-fiction et
pourtant il n'en est rien car avant
d'aller chercher du lithium sur des
astéroïdes ou de construire à des usines
sur Mars nous irons sur la lune et si
l'on veut y rester un peu plus que que
quelques heures il faudra forcément
utiliser les ressources disponibles sur
place à commencer par l'eau glacée qui
se trouve au fond des cratères pour
fabriquer de l'oxygène et du carburant
pour pour le retour et tout cela c'est
pour 2030 hautement dit autrement dit
pardon pour pour demain en revanche ce
n'est pas forcément pour nous car
aujourd'hui ce sont les États-Unis et la
Chine qui font la course en tête et nos
entreprises qui voient des opportunités
leur échapper c'est ce qui nous amène à
l'audition d'aujourd'hui car le sujet
des ressources spatiales en fait n'est
qu'une nouvelle illustration de deux
tendances de fond d'une part la
militarisation de l'espace aujourd'hui
terrain d'affrontement stratégique
à part entière d'autre part la place
croissante des acteurs privés avec ce
que l'on appelle le new space pour
évoquer ces deux aspects en prenant un
peu de recul qui mieux qu'un ancien
militaire aujourd'hui entrepreneur mon
général vous avez été le premier
commandant de l'espace la Space force à
la française créée en 2019 si vous êtes
aujourd'hui retraitée votre expérience
n'est pas moins précieuse pour nous
aider à prendre la mesure des nouveaux
défis et des nouvelles menaces qui
existent avec lookup space vous voyez
maintenant les choses du côté des
entreprises quel est votre marché à quel
besoin répondez-vous le soutien public
en France et en Europe est-il à la
mesure de ce qui se fait aux États-Unis
comment ne pas passer à côté des futurs
opportunités économiques qui sont autant
pardon qui sont autant de leviers
d'indépendance stratégique l'un des
points communs entre ces deux univers
c'est l'importance cruciale de la
maîtrise des données
si ce sujet est l'une des façons
d'entrer dans un domaine bien plus vaste
je vous laisse à présent la parole pour
nous en parler et vous remercions encore
de votre présence aujourd'hui
voilà merci beaucoup
mesdames et messieurs sénateurs donc
merci de m'inviter pour cette séance le
sujet est vaste donc je veux dire que
l'intitulé
m'a donné à réfléchir beaucoup pour
savoir comment j'allais répondre à la
question et finalement j'ai décidé de
planter un décor et ensuite évidemment
qui se terminera par le CUP space et les
enjeux de surveillance de l'espace
et d'ouvrir la porte sur certains sujets
qu'on pourra aborder dans les questions
voilà et donc pour commencer je voudrais
vous vous rappeler un élément historique
qui à mon avis assez intéressant vous
vous connaissez sans doute l'histoire
qui est arrivé en mai 1960 au dessus du
territoire de l'Union soviétique ou un
U2 américain a été abattu par les Russes
et le pilote fait prisonnier Gary Powers
ça a été un grand scandale diplomatique
et donc évidemment à l'époque au
paroxysme de la guerre froide en jeu
c'était de
de connaître le territoire ennemi son
dispositif de savoir où étaient les
sites de lancement de missile balistique
les aéroports les ports etc et donc on
faisait du renseignement avec des avions
évidemment on a arrêté aussitôt les
Américains ont été aussitôt sur volet de
territoire soviétique et ont accéléré
sur le programme leur programme spatial
et donc ils avaient un programme qui
s'appelait le programme corona
qui a donné lieu peu après donc
la destruction de l'avion de Carry
powers au lancement on a du 1er
satellite de reconnaissance de
l'histoire le satellite discover
américain en tout cas
discover 14
qui en quelques heures de mission a
rapporté des photographies de quatre
plus de 4 millions de kilomètres carrés
du territoire de l'Union soviétique
une surface qu'un avion U2 aurait
couverte en 24 missions
et donc au cours de cette mission il l'a
reconnu les analystes américains ont pu
reconnaître 64 aérodrome militaires 26
sites de missile solaire inconnus
identifiés et par la suite ce programme
corona a donné lieu en une dizaine
d'années à plus de 145 missions qui ont
permis de couvrir 88 fois la surface du
de l'Union soviétique d'élabore une
cartographie exhaustive de localiser
tous les sites de missiles balistiques
tous les sites anti-missiles toutes les
bases navales sous-marines et ainsi que
nombre de sites militaires industriels
dont les Américains ignoraient
l'existence donc cette enfin cette
anecdote illustre combien dès les
origines le spatial et la donnée ont été
intrinsèquement mêlés puisque tout ce
que je viens d'indiquer ce sont des
alors on parlerait aujourd'hui en octet
ou en térao de données mais ce sont
finalement des terrains à octets de
données
et finalement c'est exactement ça
aujourd'hui l'espace que ça soit pour
des applications militaires aussi
civiles offrent des infrastructures qui
se sont démocratisées qui ne sont plus
uniquement mise en oeuvre par des
acteurs publics ou militaires mais qui
sont également mises en oeuvre par des
acteurs et de plus en plus par des
acteurs privés à des fins commerciales
et l'espace offre des infrastructures
qui
fournissent des quantités
extraordinaires de données utilisées
pour des fins institutionnels
gouvernementales défenses commerciales
dans tous les domaines l'infrastructure
développement d'agriculture les la
surveillance de des paramètres
essentiels du climat le la mesure du
stress hydrique des sols l'éducation la
santé la finance l'énergie les réseaux
logistiques etc
et ce phénomène ne fait que s'accélérer
je vais vous donner quelques exemples
pour illustrer cela
vous avez par exemple quand on regarde
le rapport le dernier rapport sur le
marché
aval ce qu'on appelle le marché aval de
l'observation de la Terre et du GNSS
donc le GNSS c'est le système de
navigation et de positionnement et de
synchronisation par satellite qui sont
donnés par système américain GPS le
système européen Galileo ou le système
russe glonas ou chinois à Beidou et bien
le marché des dispositifs GNSS lui-même
passe de 6 milliards d'unités
c'est-à-dire le récepteur GNSS sur Terre
en 2021 à environ 11 milliards selon le
Space Agency euspa qui n'est pas qui
n'est pas Laurent Space Agency les arts
qui est encore un autre organisme
les recettes de ce marché aval
issus du GNSS devraient passer de 200
milliards d'euros en 2021 à peu près 500
milliards d'euros en 2031 les livraisons
de le récepteur GNSS vont passer de 2
milliards par an en 2021 à 2,5 milliards
d'unités annuelles en 2031 donc vous
voyez derrière toutes les applications
que ça génère et quand on regarde le
marché de l'observation de la Terre
toujours selon le spa c'est un marché
qui a deux volets la donnée et les
services élaborés à partir de la donnée
donc ça a marché qui est en croissance
régulière et qui devrait doubler au
cours de la prochaine décennie alors
sous l'impulsion de différents facteurs
les évolutions politiques européennes et
mondiales en matière de climat de Green
Deal l'accord de Paris mais également
les besoins croissants dans tous les
domaines j'en ai cité quelques-uns tout
à l'heure et le recours de plus en plus
large aux opérateurs privés commerciaux
par les acteurs institutionnels et
notamment défenses et enfin les avancées
sur toutes les technologies et
développement très rapide de
de Cloud que ce soit du storage ou de
Computing et également de machine
learning et d'intelligence artificielle
et ce marché
devrait également doubler
dans le domaine à la fois des services
et des données brutes et des services à
valeur ajoutée
alors si je voudrais sur ce point
terminé sur ce point en attirant votre
attention sur sur un sujet que vous
connaissez sans doute mais le spatial
est devenu depuis 10 ou 15 ans le pivot
l'élément central du regain de la
digitalisation du monde via ces
infrastructures qui se déploient et qui
sont de plus en plus accessibles mais il
y a également c'est c'est
ruptures dans le domaine du Cloud
Computing et la connectivité
alors l'usage du clan de copenic c'est
un fait majeur on sépare les fonctions
de servitude stockage des données et
logiciels et les fonctions d'exécution
vous savez que les les grands acteurs
américains ont une position ultra
dominante dans le domaine dans le
secteur numérique en déployant de
grandes infrastructures de cloud
computing qui nécessite une très forte
connectivité donc une coïnité globale au
sens anglon sec anglo-saxon du terme
donc mondial aujourd'hui cette
connectivité repose essentiellement sur
des câbles sous-marins 99% des données
mondiales et des échanges intercontents
passent par des câbles sous-marins les
les vacances acteurs américains les
gafam
possède en pleine propriété ou en
copropriété 37 des câbles sous-marins
intercontinentaux existants ou en projet
Google donc alphabet et Facebook meta
ont fait le choix des câbles sous-marins
alphabet possède 21 câbles sous-marins
intercontinentaux en pleine propriété ou
en propriété partagée méta a fait ce
choix également donc Facebook avec 16
câbles sous-marins tandis qu'Amazon et
Microsoft on fait des choix différents
ils n'ont que respectivement 6 et 5
câbles sous-marins dont très peu d'aucun
propriétaire exclusive et donc ils ont
fait un choix différent ils ont fait le
choix des infrastructures spatiales
et donc c'est ce qu'on est en train de
voir se déployer on a d'un côté une
alliance entre SpaceX donc avec la
constellation Starlink et Microsoft qui
est le deuxième acteur mondial du Cloud
Computing avec un très fort soutien du
Département la Défense américain qui a
signifié un contrat de Jedi de 10
milliards d'euros pour la réflexion des
systèmes d'information vidéo des basés
sur des infrastructures spatiales et
avec une vision commune qui est le
développement technologique et numérique
spatial qui forme le pivot du projet
qu'ils appellent hoid old o main si tout
donc qui a dit la connectivité à
l'échelle mondiale avec basse latence et
des besoins de traitement de stockage
dissémination en masse
cette opérateur Microsoft a également
développé azur orbitale qui est une
offre de service à destination du
secteur spatial qui est avec la santé le
plus gros fournisseur de données
à l'échelle planétaire
de son côté Jeff Bezos donc Amazon
creeper
déploie également une infrastructure
donc il est un peu en retard sur sur
Elon Musk
Amazon Web Services et le leader mondial
avec 33% de parts de marché du cloud
computing il déploie une constellation
de 3000 satellites qui s'appelle creeper
et il a également développé une offre
qui s'appelle AWS space qui est love de
cloud computing assez semblable à celle
de de Azur à destination du secteur
spatial et ces deux acteurs sont en
train de je dirais de alors tuer le
marché ce serait sans doute en tout cas
de prendre une position
ultra dominante sur le domaine on les
voit surtout les salons spatiaux pour
des proposer leurs offres
azur space ou Amazon Web Services space
je ne vais pas alors là je vous ai
brosser un peu le décor
espace infrastructure spatiale
convergence avec le numérique espace
fournisseur de fournisseurs de données
je vous savais sans doute que le nombre
de satellites actifs en orbite connaît
une croissance quasi exponentielle donc
quand on regarde le dernier rapport de
les a sur l'environnement orbital de la
terre c'est assez effrayant quelque part
si vous avez on est passé de quelques
milliers il y a quatre ans quatre cinq
ans moins de 2000 satellites actifs
aujourd'hui mi-2023 on doit être à peu
près à 8000 satellites actifs et on sait
qu'on aura
de manière certaine plusieurs dizaines
de milliers de satellites actifs à peu
près dans les mêmes orbites c'est-à-dire
entre 400 et 1200 km à la fin de la
décennie
ce qui peut ce qui pose quand même
certains problèmes de de congestion du
trafic spatial je n'ai pas cité le
projet que vous connaissez iris II iris
square on l'appellera iris de Square qui
est le projet de connectivité
assez semblable à celui que à ceux que
j'ai décrit
mais qui est le projet souverain
européen qui a été poussé par
commissaire breton qui est qui a fait
l'objet de décision récemment mais qui
reste à mettre en oeuvre les Chinois ont
un projet qui valent qui s'appelle Gwang
qui devrait comporter à peu près 13000
satellites et
j'ai appris récemment que les Russes
qui jusque là était absente ce segment
lance un projet également de
connectivité à l'échelle mondiale donc
ce sont des projets de connectivité donc
ce sont des constellations qui sont
déployées dans les orbits de base
pourquoi parce qu'on a des très faibles
temps de latence c'est-à-dire que les
trajets le temps de trajet entre les
stations sol et les stations et les
satellites sont extrêmement courts
contrairement à ce qu'on connaissait ce
qu'on connaissait sur les satellites en
géostationnaire qui sont à 36000 km de
la Terre et donc ça ouvre des
perspectives
très très grandes d'autant qu'on peut
avec les technologies de communication
optique laser entre satellite se passer
d'infrastructures sol
donc voilà vous avez différents projets
qui se déploient
donc on voit bien que l'espace devient
un enjeu très très fort et que il y a il
y a
une une
basculement de des en tout cas qui qui
timide encore mais qui s'initie et qui
on verra il faudra voir si ça se
confirme des infrastructures terrestres
qui sont quand même à tous égards
vulnérables et qui présentent des
inconvénients les câbles sous-marins
sont coûteux à déployer et ils sont
vulnérables on a on sait qu'il y a des
menaces sur les caps souverains donc
certains ont fait le choix de ces
infrastructures spatiales
je ne reviens pas sur le sujet de la
conflictualité dans l'espace mais on
pourra revenir dans la question si vous
le souhaitez la question de
l'arsenalisation de l'espace qui est un
sujet que j'ai eu à traiter pendant
quatre ans dans mes fonctions
précédentes mais que je continue à
regarder de près
mais je voudrais terminer sur le sujet
de la surveillance de l'espace vous avez
compris qu'à ce sujet de congestion de
l'espace il y a le sujet de la
conflictualité avec l'apparition des
menaces orbitales je parle des menaces
orbitales donc de ces engins il y a des
exemples encore très récents et actuels
de de
de situation ou des satellites russes et
chinois viennent enfin chinois
développent des capacités de manoeuvre
en orbite essentiellement
géostationnaire pour le moment
d'ailleurs mais ils viennent de finir
l'expérimentation le deuxième vol de
leur avion spatiale chinois de qui a été
un vol de longue durée
quant aux Russes et on a eu un événement
début 2020 entre deux situations un peu
de conflictuel entre satellites russes
et américains
qui a duré quelques mois et c'est un
événement qui il y a un nouvel événement
en cours depuis fin 2022 entre à nouveau
un satellite russe un salt américain
donc ce qu'on voit apparaître ce sont
ces menaces orbitales qui sont capables
de s'approcher genre c'est une
technologie qu'on maîtrisait depuis des
années on avait le rapprochement orbital
on sait faire depuis quasiment et début
de la conquête de l'espace c'est quelque
chose qu'on avait un peu laissé de côté
et qui revient
aujourd'hui avec clairement des
applications militaires plutôt
inquiétantes
voilà alors look up space la société que
vous avez mentionné que j'ai que j'ai
cofondé avec
un cadre dirigeant du CNES l'agence
spatiale dans le nom et Juan Carlos de
l'ado qui était chef du service
surveillance de l'espace du CNES et qui
lui avait en charge les calculs le suivi
des objets en orbite basse et les
calculs de conjonction de collision
possible entre ces objets là
à défenses civiles en fournissant un
service d'anticollision qui s'appelait
d'abord à Kaiser et qui ensuite a été
incorporé dans un service public fourni
par la Commission à travers un organisme
s'appelle eusset européenne space sur 25
tracking
alors lui Ron Carlos a eu l'occasion de
expert international de la question des
débris je n'ai pas parlé des débris mais
vous savez sans doute vous avez lu qu'il
y a aujourd'hui alors depuis le début de
l'activité spatiale humaine
on a développé malheureusement un
certain nombre de débris soit par
l'activité normale c'est-à-dire que
lorsque Sputnik 1 en 1957 va dans
l'espace en fait on met pas un objet
dans l'espace mais on en met trois mais
la capsule la capsule Spoutnik mais on
met également la coiffe sous laquelle se
trouvait Spoutnik et on y laisse
également en orbite le dernier étage de
la fusée semurcas qui a mis en orbite
Spoutnik donc ça fait trois objets dont
deux débris
et en fait ceci existe toujours donc
vous allez trouver un orbite basse
quelques milliers d'objets de grande
taille de quelques centaines à quelques
tonnes qui sont essentiellement des
anciens satellites morts non des
orbitées ou des étages de fusée qui ont
mis en orbite ces satellites et qui sont
restés ensuite en orbite mais on va
trouver également des objets de taille
inférieure quelques dizaines de
centimètres quelques centimètres ou
quelques millimètres ces objets dans
l'espace se déplacent à des vitesses
considérables c'est 28000 km/h en orbite
basse donc deux objets qui se
rencontrent ça fait des vitesses
relatives de 56000 km heure un débris
d'un centimètre métallique d'un
centimètre ça à peu près la même énergie
cinétique qu'une boule de bowling vous
avez tous sans pratiquer bowling donc
c'est assez lourd lancé à 100 km/h donc
voilà un objet un centimètre on s'est
protégé alors il y en a aujourd'hui 36
plus de 36 000 en orbite dont seulement
22000 sont répertoriés catalogués suivi
de plus de 10 cm
et il y en a à peu près un million de
plus d'un centimètre
on sait protéger les infrastructures
spatiales contre des objets de moins
d'un centimètre et là on en compte
énormément à peu près 100 millions
d'après des évolutions statistiques
puisqu'on ne sait pas les détecter donc
la Station spatiale internationale
comporte des blindages qui absorbent les
chocs des de ces petites de ces petits
débris jusqu'à 1 cm
à partir de 10 cm on sait les détecter
et on sait initier des manœuvres pour
éviter ces débris entre 1 et centimètres
et 10 cm on ne sait pas
les blindages ne n'arrêtent pas ces
objets et on est détecte pas donc on est
en grande difficulté donc congestion du
trafic spatial existence de ces
multiples débris qui résultent soit de
l'activité humaine normale soit
d'incidents comme des collisions entre
deux satellites c'est arrivé à deux
reprises enfin en tout cas deux de
collisions importantes ou les tirs de
missiles effectués par la Chine en 2007
ou plus récemment par la Russie en 2021
et puis enfin ces menaces orbitales que
j'ai citées donc ce que ce que nous
avons décidé Ron Carlos et moi c'est
d'essayer de contribuer à résoudre ce
problème
parce que notre
devise en quelque sorte c'est que c'est
c'est d'être enfin notre
inspiration c'est d'être engagé ou comme
ça est une société engagée pour le
maintien de la soutenabilité ou de la
pérennité des activités spatiales en
orbite compte tenu de leur importance
pour le pour nos activités économiques
et nos activités sur terre parce qu'on
pense que l'avenir de l'espace se joue
sur terre et l'avenir de la terre se
joue dans l'espace notamment pour la
contribution à la compréhension des des
phénomènes climatiques et donc aux
mesures que l'on peut ensuite imaginer
pour lutter contre ce phénomène les
enjeux climatiques voilà donc notre
solution est consiste en développement
d'un radar dédié à la surveillance de
l'espace donc il sera capable de
détecter des objets de classe
centimétrique ce qui n'existe pas
aujourd'hui en Europe
une fois qu'on a démontré la capacité à
développer un radar de cette qualité là
on va déployer un réseau tout autour de
la planète de radar en bénéficiant de
cet avantage stratégique que nous avons
qui qui est
constitué par les territoires
ultramarins
et donc on aura donc un réseau de radia
d'un radar qui permettra de détecter en
permanence à chaque tour d'orbite
l'ensemble des objets en orbite et ça ça
va constituer puisque vous avez compris
qu'il y a des des centaines de milliers
d'objets qui sont détectables par notre
qui seront détectables par notre réseau
des quantités phénoménales de données
qu'il faut être capable de rapatrier de
sécuriser de traiter pour en tirer de
l'information
et donc on développe à côté également
une plateforme numérique avec des
partenaires industriels sur la partie
radar on est on est on a constitué un
consortium avec deux acteurs industriels
et 9 sous-traitants qui sont toutes des
PME ti françaises et des centres de
recherche et sur la partie digitale
numérique donc on développe également
une plateforme numérique qui est assez
innovante qui fera l'objet également de
plusieurs brevets avec la capacité à
traîner traiter de données de manière
massive hétérogène agnostiques alors on
n'utilise pas les mots les buzz World
que sont intelligents artificielle
machine learning etc en revanche on a
des algorithmes propriétaires qui
permettent de faire ça et de calculer en
temps réel des conjonctions de collision
possible et de caractériser des
comportements de détecter caractériser
des comportements inhabituels dans
l'espace c'est ça correspond plutôt à
des besoins de défense
seul acteur qui fait ça de manière
exhaustive est américain c'est une
start-up qui a été créée en 2017 et qui
a déjà levé 82 millions de dollars on a
des levée de fond qui est beaucoup plus
modeste on est soutenu par l'état
français puisque on est
on est en attente d'une décision enfin
de décision finale de France 2030
poursuivant sonner le développement à la
fois du radar mais également de la
plateforme digitale
il y a un fort intérêt du ministère des
armées pour ce qu'on fait
et donc il y a levée de fonds et donc je
vous disais que le la difficulté que
nous avons eu dans la levée de fonds
d'entrepreneur mais c'est que on a
constaté de difficultés la première
c'est que quand vous parlez de
souveraineté c'est pas du tout un atout
pour les fonds d'investissement nous on
a naïvement cru je dirais même bêtement
cru que
Swan et c'était un enjeu pas du tout
c'est inventé c'est handicap en fait
quand vous levez le fond parce que ça
veut dire que vous ne pourrez pas
revendre la société un acteur américain
qui vous offrir un pont d'or pour
acheter ce que vous avez fait donc vous
limitez les possibilités les
possibilités d'Exit pour les fonds
d'investissement
et la deuxième chose qu'on a constaté
c'est que
il y avait des interrogations très
fortes sur le marché l'existence même
d'un marché donc le il y a différentes
études de marché n'existe pas
aujourd'hui oui il est il était émergent
donc il est très faible très petit ce
qu'on voit c'est que d'année en année
les évaluations
réhausse
le monde le montant global du marché à
l'horizon 2030 donc on est passé en deux
ans de 600 millions de de dollars
presque 2 milliards de dollars ce qui
reste un micro marché le marché du jeu
vidéo en France est 5 milliards d'euros
vous voyez c'est comme ça reste un tout
petit marché
donc des interrogations sur le marché
nous on a nous on a la conviction que ce
marché va être là parce qu'il y a un
besoin extrêmement fort défense civile
qu'aujourd'hui peu d'acteurs se soucient
de ce qui se passe dans l'espace de
acteurs spatiaux parce que soit ils
acceptent de perdre des plateformes et
donc de la remplacer mais je pense qu'il
y aura un moment un besoin de réguler
pour obliger les acteurs à ne plus
accepter ça parce que la perte d'une
plateforme c'est des débris
supplémentaires et donc c'est une
pollution de l'espace qui engendre des
risques supplémentaires etc et que tous
les services en orbite qui se déploient
donc que ça soit de la Duravit de la
maintenance du déploiement de
constellation du du tourisme spatial
pour vous donner un exemple on est on a
discuté exactement américain vous savez
sans doute que plusieurs sociétés
privées américaines déploient
des des stations spatiales où on projet
de déployer des stations spatiales
privées en orbite qui vont coûter des
milliards et des dizaines de milliards
de dollars et eux n'accepteront pas
puisqu'ils sont pas couverts par les
assurances de perdre infrastructures et
investissement et donc ils ont besoin
d'acteurs comme nous pour assurer leur
sécurité donc nous on pense qu'il y a un
marché et on se dit c'est que c'est
exactement et je vais terminer là-dessus
puisque ça vous fera avec mon
introduction ce qui s'est passé avec le
marché de l'observation de la Terre
c'est-à-dire qu'il n'y avait pas de
marché de l'observation de la Terre au
début vous aviez c'était l'observation
de la Terre était faite par des
satellites de renseignements
institutionnels gouvernementaux des sens
et puis petit à petit vous avez eu des
acteurs privés qui se sont installés et
aujourd'hui le marché de l'observation
de l'espace et bien ce sont des ce sont
des sommes considérables
qui d'ailleurs vient en soutien souvent
des acteurs publics on l'a vu en Ukraine
on pourra revenir là-dessus si vous le
souhaitez dans la question et donc c'est
à peu près ce qui va se passer donc il y
a des débats en cours que ça soit aux
États-Unis en Europe sur la
structuration du marché je reviens de
Bruxelles où j'étais il y a avant-hier
dans un une séance de travail entre la
Commission et les acteurs industriels du
domaine de l'assurance de l'espace et
vous savez quand même moment il y a eu
un communiqué de la réunion des
ministres de l'espace à Bruxelles sur
l'importance à accorder au Space trafic
management qui couvre la partie
surveillance et la partie la partie
régulation et donc sans doute qui qui
présage de d'investissement enfin de
fonds de financement de l'Union
européenne pour soutenir l'émergence
d'un écosystème privé dont nous ferons
partie
merci à mon général de cette
contribution particulièrement riche je
vais peut-être passer maintenant la
parole de
rapporteurs
et Christine Labarde je sais pas
laquelle souhaite débuter
bonjour Merci monsieur le Président
mes chers collègues commandant je sais
pas si je vous appelle commandant ou
dites-moi
[Musique]
général d'accord très bien j'ai deux
questions
la première s'adresse à l'expert que
vous êtes
vous nous avez dit effectivement que un
certain temps d'acteurs étrangers et on
a pu le voir avec ma collègue Christine
avait pris de l'avance on a bien compris
que on a déjà raté la bataille des
données personnelles en Europe ce que
vous nous dites ça me laisse à penser
que malheureusement on est encore en
train de rater la bataille des données
professionnelles et donc je trouve ça
assez inquiétant qu'on soit en train de
réfléchir à la façon dont on va
intervenir dans cet espace sachant que
comme vous l'avez précisé si j'ai bien
compris vos propos la basse orbite c'est
un espace qui est quand même limité et
donc les first moveurs c'est ceux qui
vont
occuper la place et plus il se déploie
moins il reste d'espace pour les acteurs
européens pour assurer eux-mêmes leur
déploiement mon autre question vous y
avez un peu répondu c'est la question au
président de startup je m'interrogeais
sur le point de savoir si des sociétés
comme spacable que vous connaissez
peut-être qui assure des logiciels de
régulation du trafic en bassorbit et
tous les écosystème newspace en fait
français est suffisamment financé vous
avez commencé à répondre et est-ce que
vous ne pensez pas qu'il faut structurer
des très très gros fonds en fait
européen à poche profonde pour répondre
aux obstacles de
d'options de liquidité qui seront toute
façon toujours insuffisante si on s'en
tient à des financements de
premier stade et de premier
développement
qui ne permettront pas de toute façon
de mettre sur la table suffisamment de
de capitaux pour permettre l'émergence
d'acteurs français voire européen avec
des facultés de sortie
et je pense que le nouveau marché
européen aussi
devrait aider à
trouver des liquidités pour ce type de
très gros financement donc j'aurais
voulu avoir votre opinion sur ce sujet
merci alors sur votre première question
oui les espaces les orbits de basses
sont assez contestés assez convoitées et
donc contesté
moi j'avais l'habitude de parler de
français spectro orbital parce qu'il y a
le foncier physique donc les attitudes
auxquelles on se déploie et ensuite il y
a le foncier spectral et il faut des
fréquences donc il y a une bataille il y
a une course de vitesse il faut avoir
des fréquences il faut avoir des
positions orbitales donc première arrivé
premier servi aujourd'hui c'est ça la
règle donc
je crois moi je salue la l'énergie que
le commissaire breton a mis dans le
déploiement d'une constellation de
connectivité européenne souveraine qui a
qui répond à parfois des besoins
civils mais aussi défense et
institutionnelle avec une partie qui
peut rentrer dans le programme comme ça
communication satellitaire
gouvernementale donc pas uniquement
défense et qui est aussi de mon point de
vue un instrument enfin
on peut offrir de la connectivité
l'Europe peut offrir de la connectivité
largement l'Internet au débit à des
zones reculées partout dans le monde
grâce à cette constellation et ne pas
laisser les Américains ou les Chinois le
faire seul
maintenant la question c'est aussi la
question de l'infrastructure numérique
puisque vous avez bien compris mon
propos qui est de dire que déploigne
constellation c'est formidable mais il
faut derrière une infrastructure
numérique qui soit capable de faire du
stockage et du calcul
dans le Cloud et donc aujourd'hui
les consortiums qui sont en train de se
constituer pour répondre à la question
de iris II par exemple
devrait à mon sens mais je ne sais pas
si c'est le cas
inclure des grands acteurs du numérique
pas uniquement des grands acteurs du
spatial ou des télécoms
et je pense que donc voilà on en a
quelques-uns en France qui peuvent se
positionner et il y a un enjeu de faire
émerger aussi ces grands acteurs du
numérique des équivalents de Microsoft
et de Google pour la partie cloud
storage cloud computing
donc donc je pense que le verre est à
moitié plein à moitié vide il y a quand
même quelque chose qui a été mis en
place qui se lance mais c'est vrai que
en France et ça rejoint un point je l'ai
un peu abordé dans la question de
la question de l'offre et de la demande
à travers les difficultés qu'on a eu
parfois convaincre certains fonds
d'investissement qu'il y avait un marché
ou qui aura qu'il y aura un marché aux
États-Unis il y a une approche qui est
assez différente souvent c'est c'est
l'offre qui va créer la demande alors
que chez nous on pense que c'est la
demande qui crée l'offre ou qui va
générer l'offre
et du coup ça bloque beaucoup de fonds
d'investissement ou d'investisseurs
privés qui disent mais non il n'y a pas
de marché où il est trop petit oui il
est trop prospectif aux États-Unis c'est
pas du tout comme ça que ça fonctionne
voilà les gens créent une infrastructure
et derrière ça crée une offre et et
après c'est quelque chose qui
s'enclenche assez naturellement et ils
ont ils ont beaucoup plus prêt à prendre
des risques là dessus
[Musique]
donc et moi j'ai participé à mon niveau
au débat sur la nécessité d'avoir ou pas
une constellation de connectivité
européenne donc il y a deux trois ans
j'ai défendu ce projet là en face de moi
j'avais des gens qui m'aimaient il y a
pas de marché il y a pas de modèle
économique ça va coûter très cher ça va
prendre des de l'argent sur les
infrastructures spatiales de télécom
militaire parce que s'il a défense dit
oui il y a un intérêt ça veut dire que
on va nous prendre de l'argent et je
pense que ce sont tous tout ça ce sont
de pas de bons arguments voilà je vais
pas dire de mauvaise arguments mais pas
de bons arguments moi je pense qu'il y
avait un enjeu qui dépassait ça qui
était un enjeu de souveraineté un enjeu
technologique et qu'il fallait y aller
et que on ne pouvait pas ne pas être
présent c'est un peu comme le débat
qu'il y a en ce moment
qui est un peu laborieux en Europe sur
le vol habité l'exploration spatiale moi
je dis je disais un peu désespéré en
plaisantant que on était très fier il y
a deux ou trois ans de dire on a mis une
caméra sur un Rover américain qui va sur
la nous sur Mars c'est nos motif de
fierté européen européenne ou motifs
européens
bon oui c'est formidable mais c'est pas
ça fait pas rêver c'est pas c'est pas
quelque chose c'est pas un flagship
c'est pas quelque chose qui motive qui
inspirant et qui donc et qui peut être
expliqué aux citoyens et lui dire
pourquoi on met un peu d'argent
là-dedans
du vol habité une station spatiale
européenne
on voit des pays émergents ou émergés
bon certes ils ont des ressources
financières énorme mais à l'échelle de
l'Europe c'est pas quelque chose qui est
impensable bon il faut il faut
convaincre de l'utilité du projet mais
moi je prends souvent cette image de de
des grands exploits des grandes
découvertes des 15e 16e 17e siècle quand
les quand le roi Henri du Portugal lance
les vaisseaux qui quittent le Portugal
qui est une petite nation et c'est pas
très bien ce qui va trouver au bout et
bon c'est que c'est ce risque là qu'il a
pris qui a fait du Portugal une grande
nation pendant deux siècles
voilà donc je crois que ce risque là
aujourd'hui il faut le prendre il faut
il faut en étant pas forcément
complètement en sachant pas complètement
objectiver ce qu'on va trouver au bout
est-ce que ça va nous rapporter on le
voit bien en tout cas si on est absent
et les pays qui ont été absents au 15e
16e 17e siècle ils ont envie de siècles
à rattraper leur retard et donc c'est
ceux qui ont dominé les mers qui ont
pris ces risques là qui ont été les
nations prospère du 15e au 19e siècle
donc à mon avis on est un peu dans la
même configuration aujourd'hui
pour votre deuxième question qui était
qui portait sur rappelez-moi juste la
deuxième question c'était les
oui la taille des fonds d'investissement
on a déjà un petit peu répondu je pense
que on manque en France et en Europe de
à la fois donc à cette culture dont j'ai
parlé qui reste encore alors il y a un
autre élément moi que j'ai pu constater
dans mon dans mon parcours de lever de
fond
et de recherche d'investisseurs c'est
que les ce qu'on appelle la deeptech
nous on est une société deeptech
donc la diptèque en France c'est très
compliqué
si vous êtes une diptec qui des boîtes
qui déploient des infrastructures donc
des choses qui sont très capitalistiques
qui demandent des investissements lourds
nous là les investissements pour
déployer notre réseau c'est 100 millions
d'euros
et les sons d'investissement dit tech en
France adore les tout ce qui fait du sas
software de service vous avez une équipe
de développeurs
qui coûte pas très cher il y a pas
d'investissement
et en deux ans vous avez la capacité à
générer des revenus avec peu de peu
d'investissement peu d'infrastructures
dès que vous avez un projet qui
développe des infrastructures qui donc a
un vrai projet industriel
en quelque sorte donc nous on est un
vrai projet industriel on est un vrai
projet numérique aussi les deux piliers
vous l'avez compris alors là c'est très
c'est très ennuyeux beaucoup de fonds
qui sont très mal à l'aise avec ça et
qui nous disent revenez nous voir en
série a donc la deuxième levée de fonds
parce que là vous bon vous aurez des
risques donc il y a pas vraiment une
culture de risque on n'aime pas les les
projets industriels
et puis et puis il y a un autre sujet
vous l'avez évoqué c'est la taille des
fonds je pense qu'on a on manque de
fonds
sont mal à l'aise avec les sujets duo
défense souveraineté ça j'ai un peu
évoqué mais défense en particulier et
puis donc la taille des fonds on manque
en Europe aujourd'hui en France et en
Europe de font qui est la surface la
capacité des fonds américains ou qu'on
trouve aussi au Royaume-Uni ou au
Moyen-Orient
bénir Arabie Saoudite ce qui fait que si
vous voulez avoir donc des
développements
rapides des investissements puissants
pour vous développer très vite vous êtes
obligé d'aller voir aux Émirats arabes
unis en Arabie Saoudite aux États-Unis
parce qu'il y a peu de fonds alors là
aussi le vert est à moitié plein et à
moitié vide
il est à moitié plein parce qu'il y a
quand même et j'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire dans une tribune il y a deux jours
il y a quand même une volonté politique
très forte et il y a des mécanismes qui
sont mis en place il y a
on a créé le commandement de l'espace
donc il y a un intérêt très fort pour
l'espace il y a de l'exécutif il y a au
niveau européen également de la
Commission on a un directeur de l'Agence
spatiale européenne qui est aussi très
très actif très ambitieux donc il y a
quand même une dynamique
mais les outils ou les courroies de
transmission sont pas encore
complètement là que ce soit en termes de
l'organisation de gouvernance en termes
de capacité de financement et puis après
vous avez des
on pourra aller plus loin France 2030
c'est formidable moi je trouve ça
formidable on va en bénéficier
on a on va bénéficier de 60% de
subventions de développement de nos
démonstrateurs c'est très bien ça va
assez vite à partir du moment le projet
est sérieux et qui répond aux critères
mais ça a un inconvénient c'est que
c'est soumis à des conditions de fonds
propres c'est la subvention donc 1 euro
de subvention un euro de fonds propres
donc vous devez si vous avez un euro de
subvention vous devez lever 1 euro
si vous avez 8 millions de subventions
vous devez lever 8 millions donc il faut
convaincre des investisseurs de vous
prêter 8 millions sur un projet sur
lequel il y a pas de marché
ce que certains disent et qui est très
capitalistique donc
il y a dans d'autres pays des mécanismes
différents on ne soumets pas à des
conditions de fonds propres on juge que
votre projet est crédible que l'équipe
est crédible et on va on va alors
subventionner je sais pas si le mot est
le bon mais en tout cas on va financer
par des financements publics le
développement de votre projet c'est ce
qui fait aux États-Unis par exemple ça
se fait davantage par de la commande
publique qui en fait la subvention
déguisée on peut dire comme ça plutôt
que par une subvention soumise à des
conditions de son poids donc vous avez
et qui sont assez généreuses assez
faciles à obtenir et assez généreuse et
ça c'est aussi un autre point qui me
semble important c'est à dire que
et qui donne naissance à des en quelques
années à des géants alors on vient je
vais pas citer SpaceX mais on a d'autres
j'ai cité les projets de Station
spatiale internationale axiome voyageurs
par exemple c'est société Sira space qui
sont financés par par le Département de
la Défense ou par la NASA des
financements institutionnels pour partie
ce qui leur permet de lever des fonds
derrière mais sans condition
particulière simplement sur la
crédibilité du projet où vous avez des
géants d'aujourd'hui de l'imagerie
satellitaire maxark Planet aïssai et
d'autres qui sont alors ici c'est
particulier je laissais de côté c'est
pas assez européen mais planète maxer
pour pour citer les deux principaux aux
États-Unis qui ont bénéficié de contrats
très très important du Département de la
Défense pour de l'achat de l'imagerie
et pas pour de l'achat d'infrastructures
et ça c'est très vertueux parce que
d'abord c'est réversible si le service
ne vous plaît pas vous pouvez arrêter du
jour au lendemain
en finançant largement et non pas
chichement l'achat de services à ces
opérateurs là vous leur permettez de se
développer et d'innover et donc c'est ça
c'est un retour sur investissement pour
le client institutionnel qui est très
bon et donc c'est un peu tout l'objet de
la discussion qu'on a eu hier et
avant-hier à Bruxelles avec la
commission c'est c'est ne
soyez pas trop ambitieux dans le service
public que l'Union européenne va rendre
en matière de sciences de l'espace parce
que vous avez vous avez une volonté qui
est de développer la souveraineté
européenne d'un côté et on est tous
d'accord avec ça puisqu'on était un
certain nombre de sociétés autour de la
table européenne de tous les pays
européens à vouloir contribuer émerger
et devenir des acteurs mondiaux
il y a la volonté de fournir un service
une forme de service public en matière
de service d'anticollision pour l'espace
ce qui est parfaitement légitime mais
assorti d'une volonté de la commission
d'acheter des données
issues des capteurs que l'on est que
l'on va développer déployer mais à des
prix assez modestes et après avec un
service que qui sera sans doute enfin en
tout cas qui était dans leur vision
initiale qui serait sans doute de très
haut niveau et non limité au pays
membres de l'Union donc on leur a dit si
vous faites ça il y a pas il y a pas il
y a pas de possibilités de faire émerger
un écosystème industriel privé et donc
ça ne va pas fonctionner c'est à dire
que vous allez tuer les acteurs
émergents sur lesquels vous comptez pour
développer vos services voilà donc il y
a ces équilibres à trouver mais mais
voilà vous avez cité spéciale mais il y
a beaucoup d'acteurs aujourd'hui en
France il y a des acteurs installés qui
sont des industriels comme ça franc ou à
rien de groupe qui déploie des solutions
sur l'un dans l'espace mais il y a des
acteurs émergents chez un myspaceable
Space et d'autres chacun déploie une
philosophie un peu différent et déploie
des technologies différentes mon opinion
c'est que
comme dans le domaine du lancement il y
a beaucoup trop de monde à un moment
donné il va falloir ça va se consolider
ça va se voilà une façon ou d'une autre
merci
oui merci moi j'aurais juste une
question parce que je pense que c'est
intéressant pour nous de savoir aussi ce
qui intéresse et nos collègues mais vous
avez évoqué la réunion qui s'est tenue
lundi au niveau de l'Europe jusqu'à
présent vous nous avez beaucoup évoqué
les acteurs privés moi j'aimerais avoir
votre regard sur les acteurs
institutionnels et éthiques et par
exemple quelle est la quelle place la
France
occupe-t-elle est-ce qu'on est en
retrait voir est-ce qu'on participe pas
voir on est absent ou au contraire on
est
chef de fil sur certains secteurs
spécifiques enfin
dans le domaine de l'assurance de
l'espace ou dans le domaine de l'espace
en général alors
peut-être si jamais la réponse est parti
pollogie nous dire ce qu'on a abandonné
aussi on essaie de faire un peu tout
mais qu'elles donc en fait on est
vraiment fort sur rien non non on a de
beaux atouts mais j'ai eu l'occasion
enfin j'ai publié avant-hier une petite
contribution avec Jean-Baptiste gibaré
sur le sujet en disant que il fallait
qu'on ait sans doute davantage
d'ambition on a cité Churchill mais on
n'est pas sûr que ce soit Churchill
d'ailleurs c'est peut-être Oscar wild
mais enfin bon Churchill ayant tout dit
à peu près donc on est pas très loin
forcément de la vérité mais sur style a
dit viser la lune vous finirez dans les
étoiles bon mais il faut viser la lune
donc
sur sur le spatial la France et depuis
toujours une grande nation spatiale et
reconnue comme tel
c'est historiquement
on dit que c'est la troisième nationale
parce que en 1965 elle maîtrisait
l'accès à l'espace avec ses fusées
diamant et Véronique et elle a mis en
orbite son premier satellite Astérix et
donc ça ça faisait d'elle la troisième
puissance spatiale maîtrisant tout le
sexe tout le segment
et la France continue d'avoir des des
atouts considérables on a quand même
deux des plus grands
industriels mondiaux en matière de
satellites de télécommunications
notamment mais pas uniquement
d'observation donc airbus est allé
s'alignac space
fait partie nous a tout on a une volonté
politique forte avec une prise de
conscience on a un écosystème digne
space donc d'acteur émergents qui est en
train de se constituer
maintenant
et puis on a une agence spatiale qui est
qui est quand même qui est comme qui
quand même concentre des compétences
techniques extrêmement fortes
maintenant c'est vrai que de mon point
de vue
[Musique]
on a on s'est un peu endormi sur nos
lauriers je dirais
mais tout ça est apparaît le constat a
été fait en 2016 dans le rapport de
Geneviève sur Raso qui reste d'actualité
7 ans plus tard
et donc on a et donc aujourd'hui ce
qu'on croit que ce qui est en train de
se faire c'est de finalement de prendre
exemple sur le les Américains ou
la NASA qui faisait à peu près tout dans
les années 80-90 est passé à une logique
de non plus faire mais faire faire alors
elle continue à faire des choses avec
une expertise technique très forte mais
elle a davantage
favoriser l'émergence secteur privé qui
aujourd'hui sont à la pointe de
l'innovation de l'audace de la prise de
risque avec des investissements privés
et donc on connaît le résultat avec un
Space X qui aujourd'hui enfin je crois
qu'il a prévu pour 2023 200 lancements
donc c'est
ou 2024 peut-être
donc c'est un lancement par semaine
depuis maintenant presque un an là où
l'Europe fait cette année 5 lancements
pour des raisons que on connaît mais
donc oui alors tout n'est pas perdu
néanmoins
on a écrit dans notre tribune que on
était en situation de disparition
gravitaire bon c'est un terme de
technoning des plaques à un moment donné
vous avez un trou qui s'ouvre et poumons
disparaît alors qu'on était là il y a un
moment donné
mais mais encore une fois on a des
atouts très forts on a une volonté
politique on a un dispositif en 2030 il
y a un milliard et demi d'euros
subventions pour de l'espace pour
l'espace dont un milliard pour des
acteurs émergents donc tout ça et tout
ça est très bien et il y a des gens qui
ont envie de faire des choses maintenant
il y a encore des choses à améliorer je
pense que sur la question de
l'organisation de la gouvernance en
France
je pense qu'on pourrait faire mieux il y
a aussi la question du rôle en Europe de
la place de la France dans l'Europe et
donc de l'Europe parce que la France la
France doit rester peu Édouard rester
une nations spatiale mais à mon avis
elle ne peut plus porter seule des
projets enfin ne peut pas apporter seul
des projets comme une station spatiale
internationale etc ça c'est fini des
pays comme les émirs arabes unis peuvent
le faire parce qu'ils ont des ressources
financières très importantes mais et ils
le font d'ailleurs
mais mais la France non donc la France
c'est la question c'est la place c'est
l'ambition européenne et la place de la
France dans cette ambition européenne à
mon sens
et si on arrive à résoudre cette
question qui passe aussi par à mon avis
une réflexion sur la un peu la
gouvernance et l'organisation du
européen c'est à dire l'articulation
entre les agences nationales et donc les
États membres d'une part la Commission
européenne autre part et l'Agence
spatiale européenne les a d'autre part
question qui n'est pas réglé qui mais
qui qui
[Musique]
aujourd'hui ça existe ça fonctionne mais
mais c'est quand même ça reste une
question difficile
[Musique]
je pense que si on arrive à avancer sur
ces sujets là l'Europe peut avoir une
vraie vraie ambition spatiale et revenir
au meilleur niveau et la France joue un
rôle particulier sur le domaine de
l'assurance de l'espace alors là très
clairement la France a toujours été
leader en Europe
précurseur et leader ce qu'aujourd'hui
le SST dont je vous ai parlé tout à
l'heure européenne space sur une
centracking ce qui est un consortium
constitué je crois en 2007 17 par là je
ferai vérifier la date mais dont la
France a fait partie dès le début
et qui doit fournir des services
d'anticollision de rentrer à risque de
fragmentation
en orbite
et bien dans ce consortium la France
joue un rôle central
d'abord parce que c'est elle qui fournit
le plus de données
grâce à son radar grave qui est un radar
du ministère des armées que le
commandement de l'espace met en oeuvre
et ensuite parce que tous les calculs de
conjonction de collision sont fait par
le CNES sont fournis par le CNES
donc ce dispositif est en train
d'évoluer il va sans doute se structurer
monter en gamme fournir des services de
plus en plus évolués mais la question
c'est je pense que il faut de mon point
de vue là aussi
il faut faire en sorte que la France a
toujours été précurseur leader reste
précurseur à leader dans cette capacité
européenne qui est en train de se
structurer
qui sera le pendant d'une capacité
américaine d'ailleurs qui existe déjà
aujourd'hui qu'à travers le catalogue
space track et les messages de
conjonction de collision de risque de
collision qui sont fournis par les
Américains de manière gratuite mais
également dans le secteur commercial
aujourd'hui ce sont les Américains qui
ont le monopole du marché sur le secteur
commercial avec juste un acteur léoz
mais il y en a d'autres ils ont
Analytics et puis et puis d'autres
encore comme spox nav etc donc il y a un
enjeu il y a un enjeu qui est un enjeu
clairement de de compétitivité il faut
et donc de monopole de marché et donc de
souveraineté derrière
merci
chers collègues René Paul
vous avez fait la comparaison de la
découverte des à travers les mers des
différents pays
et là pour l'espace est-ce que on peut
faire la comparaison
identique en ce qui concerne les
infrastructures terrestres donc les
câbles sous-marins et maintenant les
infrastructures spatiales entre la le
cuivre et la fibre est-ce qu'il y aura
une disparition des câbles
souterrains à terme parce que les pays
en ont son propriétaire ou on dépend
essentiellement des Gafa
aujourd'hui alors je suis pas
spécialement non je suis pas un spécial
des Caps sous-marins ce que
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on a assisté en
quelques années à ils ont été déployés
quand même essentiellement alors les
doit y avoir des câbles gouvernementaux
imagine mais là je ferai demander aux
spécialistes mais ils étaient déployés
essentiellement par les opérateurs de
télécom et aujourd'hui sont déployés par
les opérateurs du numérique
ce que ce qui est sûr c'est que pour
répondre rapidement à votre question
c'est que on a la constellation Starlink
et que Elon Musk a déployé a déjà un
million et demi d'abonnés
Starlink avait voulu répondre à un appel
d'offre du gouvernement américain pour
équiper des zones reculées des
États-Unis en internet un accès Internet
au début au début qu'il a été il n'a pas
été autorisé à répondre à l'appel
d'offres qu'il a il a fait une action
justice pour annuler cette décision il a
finalement été autorisé et il a remporté
une partie de l'appel d'ov sur certains
États ou certaines zones
pour un montant quand même important ce
qui veut dire quand même que c'est c'est
ça entoure une porte sur le en tout cas
ça pose la question du remplacement des
infrastructures terrestres par des
infrastructures spatiales
bon j'ai une modeste propriété en
Normandie et à la campagne dans le Pays
d'Auge et c'est assez amusant de voir
ces poteaux en bois qui subsiste le long
des routes des petites routes qui
amenaient le téléphone jusqu'au ferme
les plus reculées aujourd'hui c'est
poteau en bois sont toujours là il y a
plus de câbles dessus ou alors une pente
un peu tristement en revanche vous avez
les relais 5G qui ont été installés un
peu partout donc on a abandonné une
infrastructure pour une autre et on peut
se poser la question de savoir si un
jour on aura parce que la 5G on l'aura
bientôt par satellite vous avez des
sociétés startups qui travaillent
là-dessus
et donc on peut se poser la question de
savoir si demain on n'aura pas
encore des antennes 5G alors j'espère
qu'elles sont démantelées mais que tout
passera pas par satellite
mais bon ce qui pose d'autres questions
la question de la soutenabilité de ces
infrastructures de leur emplacement etc
mais donc à titre personnel par exemple
je ne suis pas je suis assez reculé dans
cette propriété en Normandie donc je
n'ai pas de fibres je n'ai rien donc je
vais sans doute m'équiper d'un terminal
Starling pour avoir internet
donc voilà modestement un exemple ou les
infrastructures spatiales vont remplacer
pour un usage domestique tout à fait
normal infrastructure terrestre
[Musique]
non alors un peu en vrac mais aussi des
pour rebondir sur des choses que nous on
a pu entendre et sur lesquels on
aimerait recueillir votre votre réaction
déjà sur la gouvernance de l'espace au
niveau français on est passé d'une
tutelle Ministère de la Recherche à une
tutelle ministère de l'économie il y a
deux trois ans deux ou deux trois 2019
donc
et donc aujourd'hui
comment tout ça s'organise alors
qu'effectivement le ministère des armées
s'est vu adjoindre la terminologie
espace et voilà la lutte d'influence ou
pas entre les différents pans de
l'action gouvernementale
ensuite pareil on a pas mal
évoqué les questions de
comment dire contrôle européen enfin en
tout cas de devoir respecter la
réglementation des aides d'État dans un
secteur qui est quand même une politique
qui est à mon avis moins national Queen
enfin on sera jamais la France sera
jamais un leader de l'espace toute seule
enfin on révisera pas avec les
États-Unis ou la Chine c'est l'Union
européenne qui peut le faire et pour
autant on voit que dans certains
secteurs on est dans ce qu'on
pourrait faire par la réglementation sur
les aides d'État donc
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ça et aussi
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de la règle
non écrite du retour géographique dans
les discussions entre États membres pour
financer pour financer des projets
là je m'adresse aussi aux militaires
aujourd'hui certains États ont mis en
place un droit particulier
sur sur la lune et notamment sur
l'exploitation des ressources lunaires
on a bien conscience que le premier
arrivé
bénéficiera de conditions d'implantation
très favorable et elles sont pas
nombreuses donc est-ce à dire qu'on va
avoir des zones militarisées
sur la lune pour faire respecter son
droit de première arrivée alors même qui
reste quand même après une incertitude
juridique sur le le cadre qui entoure
cet espace en tant que tel appartient
pas à la frontière d'un pays
voilà deux trois points je sais pas si
tu veux rajouter des choses
oui merci juste quelque chose peut-être
qui est un peu philosophique mais tout
ce dont on parle finalement c'est quand
même très très conditionné aussi à
l'acceptabilité
sociale des nouvelles générations de ce
qu'on veut aller faire dans ces espaces
et est-ce que vous sentez
des forces de résistance ou est-ce que
c'est tellement
comment dire un sujet de niche aux yeux
du grand public pour l'instant personne
ne regarde mais est-ce que du point de
vue idéologique on va pas se
fracasser en fait sur des
tenants de théories qui vont dire les
sons ces espaces vierges arrêtons le
massacre et ne reproduisons pas dans
l'espace ce qui nous met dans la
situation dans laquelle on se trouve
aujourd'hui sur la planète Terre avec
les effets du dérèglement climatique par
exemple
alors sur la gouvernance
moi je pense qu'on peut faire mieux
voilà
c'est
une édition publique donc c'est
difficile
non non je pense qu'on peut faire mieux
non mais de toute façon c'est exactement
le l'objet encore pardonnez-moi ça fait
la première fois que j'en parle mais de
de modeste contribution qu'on a qu'elles
ont écrites avec Jean-Baptiste gibary
hier dans la tribune avant-hier c'est de
dire que
au-delà de l'ambition qu'il faut avoir
c'est c'est de dire qu'il faut aussi
sans doute
repenser ou améliorer notre organisation
et notre gouvernance vous l'avez dit
aujourd'hui le ministère de l'Économie
et devenu le ministère de l'espace
depuis 2019 ou 2020
ce qui ce qui en soit ni une bonne ni
une mauvaise chose c'est je pense que
c'était une bonne chose au moment où ça
a été fait parce que
en fait il y a trois façons d'aborder
l'espace vous avez un tropisme
scientifique recherche scientifique
exploration très fort qui était quand
même incarné par le Messie à l'époque
vous avez un tropisme défense donc le
ministère des armées et vous avez un
tropisme économie industrie
développement du marché aval dans stream
market sur la donnée etc etc et qui est
donc été pris en main par le ministère
économie et qui est parfaitement
légitime mais donc l'idée c'était de
dans cette logique de non plus ferme et
faire faire c'était de faire faire donc
de de d'aider des acteurs émergents à
développer et à développer ces secteurs
économiques des sociétés qui devient des
champions mondiaux etc donc mais
aujourd'hui ces trois tropismes
perdure je pense et
se rejoignent pas complètement toujours
je pense en tout cas c'est difficile
d'en faire la synthèse et si alors dans
le je crois le dans le texte qui a donné
un ministère de l'Économie la
responsabilité de l'espace qui en fait
le ministère de l'espace je crois dans
ces attribution il écrit qu'il est
responsable de la politique
espace de la France
mais en réalité je pense je crois que
les choses se passent un peu
différemment
je crois que c'est plus compliqué que ça
aujourd'hui mon point de vue c'est que
il manque en France un organisme
interministériel
placé au bon niveau
qui soit capable de proposer d'élaborer
de proposer une politique spatiale
nationale articulée avec évidemment des
partenaires européens et l'Europe
et ensuite dans faciliter la mise en
oeuvre et dans tout en étant dans un
mode de co-construction c'est-à-dire
qu'il s'agit pas de faire quelque chose
dans une tour d'ivoire et ensuite de
faire un magnifique papier beaucoup de
comme autour il s'agit de faire quelque
chose de très opérationnel c'est mon
point de vue mais bon c'est aussi mon ma
culture
il s'agit pas comme disait Gérald De
Gaulle de faire un comité Théodule ou
Gaspard
mais de faire quelque chose qui
fonctionne donc il faut avec une logique
et pour faire ça il faut que ça soit
vraiment placé au bon niveau et au bon
niveau donc alors on appellera ça comme
on veut un conseil national de l'espace
un secrétaire général pour l'espace mais
certains pays se sont dotés de ça donc
les Américains les tous premiers donc
c'est un dispositif qui a existé dès les
débuts de l'aventure spatiale qui était
toujours été présidée par le
vice-président aux États-Unis donc c'est
si vous regardez à nouveau ce film
fantastique l'étoffe des héros vous avez
Lindon Johnson qui préside le Conseil
national de l'espace et qui chapeaute
tout le développement des programmes
Gemini et Mercury
ce conseil national de l'espace a été
mis en sommeil puis recréer sous Reagan
puis remis en sommeil puis recréer par
Trump confirmé par Biden et ce conseil
national l'espace il est présidé par le
vice-président des États-Unis donc il
est au bon niveau il réunit autour de la
table tous les ministères concernés et
souvent c'est pas toujours ceux auxquels
on pense en premier vous avez le
ministère de l'Éducation vous avez le
ministère des Transports vous avez le
ministère de la Défense vous avez mis
ces industrie l'économie etc du commerce
aux États-Unis enfin les départements
il s'appuie sur un groupe de haut niveau
d'experts qui également associe
l'industrie des anciens astronaute et
qui adressent tous les sujets qui font
des recommandations
au conseil national de l'espace et donc
le Conseil national de l'espace s'appuie
sur une structure permanente très légère
il y a un secrétaire général ou un
exécutif secrétari qui est un monsieur
assez important aux États-Unis qui est
le bras droit de kamalaaris la
vice-présidente et c'est lui qui
coordonne tous les travaux du Conseil
national de l'espace qui organise les
réunions et qui et ce conseil national
depuis qu'il a été créé donc Trump et
Biden tous les deux administrations a
émis 6 ou 7 directives politiques space
policiers directives ce qui traite de
sujets aussi divers que la cybersécurité
des systèmes spatiaux
la création de l'aspects force
américaine le retour sur la lune
l'intégration des partenaires
commerciaux
une politique en matière de propulsion
nucléaire dans l'espace enfin voilà des
sujets qui sont très politiques et qui
donnent des directives et ensuite qui
sont qui doivent être évidemment mises
en oeuvre par les acteurs institution
nels et privés donc moi je pense qu'on
manque aujourd'hui
d'un organisme de ce type là qui serait
capable sous l'autorité du Président de
la République ou du Premier ministre
indéfinir mais donc c'est quand je dis
au plus haut niveau c'est ça de réunir
tous les acteurs et d'établir des
directives politiques qui ensuite soit
capable d'en coordonner la mise en
oeuvre en stimulant l'écosystème il
s'agit pas il s'agit pas d'ailleurs de
réguler parce que
on est on est souvent très fort pour
faire des commissions de régulation je
pense que là il faut faire une
commission de libération
voilà vous savez enfin je veux être un
peu provocateur mais on a fait une
commission de régulation de l'énergie on
aurait peut-être fait on aurait
peut-être fait un conseil national de
l'énergie il y a 15 ans on aurait
peut-être pas de difficulté qu'on a
aujourd'hui avec DF et d'autres sujets
et l'énergie nucléaire voilà donc ça
c'est mon point de vue
voilà la difficulté qu'on a en France
effectivement que et dire dire ce que je
viens de dire ça n'est pas du tout jeter
la pierre aux différents acteurs qui
font un travail formidable que ce soit
mystère de l'économie ministère de
l'enseignement supérieur recherche de ou
au ministère des armées ou au CNES mais
je pense que c'est il y a besoin
aujourd'hui sans doute d'un chef
d'orchestre pour aller plus loin voilà
sur sur la question de
déréglementations
bon je passe certains d'avoir
compris exactement ce qu'il y a derrière
votre question
mais bon je fais finalement je pense
qu'il y a des domaines dans lesquels il
faut il faut de la régulation
typiquement il y a absolument pas de
régulation dans la trafic spatial
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il faut la
régulation pas tellement pour faire du
contrôle spatial
d'ailleurs il y a des bas sur faut-il
parler de Space trafic management ou de
Space traffic coordination ce qui est un
peu différent mais plutôt pour imposer
des un certain nombre de normes qui
n'existent pas aujourd'hui enfin il y en
a mais pas suffisante aujourd'hui
il y a rien qui oblige un opérateur
spatial à souscrire à un service qui va
lui donner des informations pour assurer
la survie de ces satellites et donc
contribuer à la soutenabilité de
l'espace futur donc ça c'est une vraie
question et je crois qu'il y a un
travail à faire entre
les institutions donc état Commission
européenne notamment Commission
européenne les
les assureurs et les opérateurs spatiaux
pour arriver à définir ce qu'il faut
faire pour que l'espace soit soutenable
demain et ça c'est sans doute une des
conditions d'ailleurs
de l'émergence d'un secteur commercial
privé industriel de la SSA enfin donc la
surveillance de l'espace
sur la militarisation de la lune
le traité de l'espace de 67 l'interdit
voilà en théorie voilà donc il y a les
accords Artemis qui définissent un
certain nombre de principes donc ils
sont rejoints par de plus en plus de
pays la France a signé les accords
Artémis je crois il y a un an à peu près
donc ces accords Artemis se établissent
des règles de CO enfin en tout cas entre
autres établissent des règles de
cohabitation pacifique sur la lune
on peut on peut imaginer que finalement
c'est un peu ce qui
ça peut être comparable à ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui en Antarctique vous
avez des bases scientifiques ou russes
américains européens cohabitent
pacifiquement voilà c'est pas
militariser j'imagine que mais bon la
question se posera peut-être le jour où
il y aura il y aura vraiment des bases
avec des ressources à exploiter et
peut-être rare et des tensions
je ne sais pas si j'ai répondu à toutes
vos questions est-ce qu'il y avait un
point que j'ai non
ça c'est
oui oui c'est une excellente question
c'est une vraie question je pense que
derrière cette question en fait il y a
il y a celle de la du manque de
connaissance du grand public de du rôle
que je vous laisse pas aujourd'hui
et c'est pas toujours facile à expliquer
en fait
de ce que l'espace apporte aujourd'hui
dans la vie quotidienne dans l'aide de
développement dans la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique dans juste
citer quelques quelques exemples alors
je pense que c'est très mal compris je
vous donc ça sera la quatrième fois je
vous en parle mais cette petite tribune
que qu'on a publié j'ai eu des réactions
assez amusantes des commentaires un
commentaire qui dit on ferait mieux de
s'occuper déjà ce qui se passe sur terre
voilà de quelqu'un qui m'a dit ça
bon je vais pas voulu engager une
discussion avec cette personne mais
j'avais envie de lui dire mais ce qui se
passe sur terre dépense ce qui se passe
dans l'espace c'est ça le l'enjeu en
fait évidemment c'est sinon ça n'a aucun
intérêt et dépend
beaucoup beaucoup plus qu'elle ne le
pense enfin de manière considérable donc
je crois que c'est il y a un enjeu de
pédagogie à l'égard du grand public
auquel je vais essayer de contribuer
modestement puisque je suis en train de
finir le manus terminer le manuscrit
d'un livre apparaître en octobre qui
dont une large partie explique à quoi
sert l'espace avec des gens concrets
chiffrées etc voilà au-delà des enjeux
de défense souveraineté et puis des
enjeux économiques donc là il y a un
vrai jeu mais vous avez raison de dire
que il y a ce sujet et puis il y a même
si l'espace fait rêver et ça n'était pas
le cas il y a 15 ans un moment donné
c'est l'espace alors que c'est
évidemment
Elon Musk Thomas Pesquet nous aide à
remettre l'espace à la mode et donc à
susciter l'intérêt
[Musique]
et la personne qui m'a dit ça m'a dit
mais à chaque fois qu'on parle d'espace
c'est à peu près la même chose on a un
deux trois journalistes voilà
donc vous voyez c'est quand même une
anecdote qui est oui c'est une anecdote
qui est assez significative
alors que les enjeux alors que les
enjeux sont considérables stratégiques
économiques
absolument donc à la fois sur donc il y
a un long travail de pédagogie qui a été
entrepris depuis maintenant deux ans
et de l'explication de conviction que
l'espace est mais vous savez enfin vous
prenez je pense 8 personnes sur 10 dans
la rue ne savent pas que le GPS est
donné par des systèmes spatiaux
[Musique]
ne savent pas que la synchronisation des
transactions bancaires dans le monde
sont faites par des satellites avec des
horloges atomiques qui sont abords des
réseaux GPS et Galilée
merci beaucoup général nous allons
essayer de faire
utile
œuvre de pédagogie pour participer à
médiatiser et à rendre toujours plus
accessible ce sujet au combien important
merci en tout cas de votre contribution
parce qu'elle elle éclaire les travaux
de nos deux collègues et les travaux de
cette délégation d'un sujet qui est
passionnant et qui vise aussi à éclairer
l'avenir comme vous l'avez fort
justement dit de ce qu'il se passe ici
bas donc un grand merci encore une fois
de votre de votre présence et puis
manquerons pas vous transmettre le fruit
de de ces travaux merci beaucoup merci à
vous